hello and welcome to discover Germany
the Travel Guide on DW today will enjoy
the wonders of the winter season
get ready to hit the slopes skiing is a
very popular winter sport here in
Germany provided there's enough snow to
be on the safe side we're going to the
highest peak in the country
that sucks pizza is a favorite with
skiers and also offers spectacular
panoramas
in order to have the mountains all to
ourselves we catch the cable car at 8:00
in the morning from the valley station
it takes just ten minutes to get up onto
the Switzer at two thousand nine hundred
sixty two metres above sea level
it's Germany's highest peak
up above the clouds were greeted by the
Sun and a breathtaking panorama of
countless mountaintops from the Italian
Dolomites to the O's tall Alps
Germany's highest alpine accommodation
is right next to the summit the Munich
House hikers and Mountaineers have been
spending summer nights here since 1897
an exhibition in the summit station
which also commemorates the first ascent
in 1820 shows just how strenuous
mountain climbing was in the past it was
also quite a job getting the cross up to
the summit when it was brought up in
1851 it took several carriers two days
to reach the top
but we want to get to the peace so we
take the cable car almost 400 meters
back down
the glacier on the suit fits flat
plateau provides quite an extensive ski
area with 20 kilometres of slopes
no need for a snow cannon up here
there's usually enough natural snow to
last the entire season from November to
May that's fortunate because to protect
the natural environment snow making
isn't even allowed and it sucks fit
splat the nine feasts ranging from easy
to moderate and difficulty aren't too
much of a challenge for experienced
skiers but it's worth the impressive
view the glacier is framed by the peaks
of the Vettes teen mountain range what
makes it special is the variety and the
fact that it's not too crowded and you
can also do a bit of off-piste skiing
here so a lot of different mountains
which are different you know level
different level and for different people
so the king came other people with
childrens and with our families it's
just perfect for me I can ski without
too much effort don't off it's true this
is a nice little ski area if you want
some relaxed skiing it's great to spend
a few hours here skiing in the mountain
air can work up quite an appetite so in
zone Alpena rustic vivere and restaurant
on the glacier we enjoy a snack in the
warm afternoon Sun sweet dumplings with
vanilla sauce a Bavarian classic
and as long as we're talking about
superlatives but some pizza also boasts
Germany's highest maple and there's
always an opportunity to do some
sledding
as the Sun sets the visitors slowly
disappear from the glacier except for a
few hearty Souls who want to spend the
night here in the ice and snow of winter
the igloo village has provided just the
right place for that and with an extra
warm sleeping bag for the icy rooms
guests have the mountain and the view
all to themselves
Christmas markets pop up across the
country in the weeks before Christmas
such markets are an old tradition in
Germany dating back to the Middle Ages
when traders would sell holiday biscuits
and toys we're visiting the famous
little market in the city of Dresden
which is also known for its Baroque
architecture art and culture
so many sites to see but where should we
head first when in Dresden in December
the choice is easy we're off to the
schnitzel marked one of the oldest
Christmas markets in Germany it features
the finest there is to offer when it
comes to Christmas festivities
the market gets its name from a
traditional pastry called streets ax the
forerunner to the famous Dresden
Christmas stollen visitors to the
streets will mocked can learn all about
how this holiday treat gets made there's
also a bakery just for kids young
confectioner's can create their very own
Christmas cookies
each year the streets and macht brings
cherished holiday traditions back to
life and Christmas wouldn't be complete
without these decorations made by hand
in the ATS kabocha region just south of
the city
we'll be back in a bit but first it's
time for a taste of Dresden's art and
culture
it would take weeks to see all of the
city's artistic treasures the royal
palace alone boasts 15 museums worth of
artifacts collected over five centuries
by the city's saxon rulers
our first stop is the Albertine ohm it's
a museum with a long and colorful
history the building underwent extensive
renovations and the exhibitions were
completely reworked in 2010 the
Albertina now has plenty of space to
display more sizeable works like those
of French sculptor aqua stored on there
are also special rooms dedicated to
contemporary paintings by the likes of
gieok Basel it's and ko Drita many
places in dresden honored the old and
the new something that can be seen in
the rebuilt fallen gyoja church
swinger palace is another one of the
city's highlights its baroque style
galleries serve as the perfect backdrop
to showcase Dresden's colorful and
historic porcelain collection
but now it's back to the streets and
mocked
in the weeks before Christmas the market
is buzzing with holiday spirit
especially after sunset
so we'll do as the Dresdeners do and
toast the day with a glass of glühwein
germany's mulled Christmas wine and
enjoyed the festive atmosphere at the
streets and mocked
not far from Dresden is a region that's
especially lovely in winter there you
can experience long standing Christmas
traditions the ad ski burger or all
mountains were once the center of mining
in Central Europe the customs made
popular by miners still characterize the
Christmas season there today
we ride on Rails into the now-closed
minds of Anna burger boo holes here
Christmas celebrations include an old
minor tradition the meta shift the meta
was the last work shift before Christmas
Eve when it was over the miners
celebrated together today the tradition
is a tourist attraction the tradition is
kept alive with mining hymns like look
after Steger comped it's nice and cozy
romantic there are candles everywhere
it's just nice in general the song
belongs to Christmas the shift before
the first advent is the pyramid the
second Advent is the meta shift on the
fourth Advent we cut our Christmas tree
and the - parade yes on the fourth
Sunday and then Christmas can come right
lentil soup is a traditional miners meal
many of the employees in the visitors
mine used to work there and remember the
harsh winters at the end of the day
you'd head home in all sorts of weather
in snowstorms and to make it easier for
the miners to find their way people lit
candles in the windows to show them the
way that's where today's traditional
illumination comes from Christmas lights
are a tradition with us as Christmas
nears we Bergen wooden arches with
candles still shine in the windows in
the Aerts mountains
freiburg is the region's oldest mining
town silver ore was discovered here in
the 12th century and made the town and
the region of Saxony rich
small towns and villages are
characteristic of the landscape in the
arts mountains one of the best known is
siphon near the Czech border small
workshops here make traditional wooden
toys and Christmas ornaments by hand
visitors can watch craftsmen making
wooden nutcrackers or figures that smoke
incense
Maiden's siphon is known around the
world as a seal of quality
up to 30,000 people flocked to the small
town on the weekends before Christmas
people here have been making wooden
figures for almost 100 years we collect
them because they're so pretty you
really appreciate them once you see how
they're made the traditional high point
before Christmas is the miners parades
like Schnee bags little fest the
region's miners associations proudly
display their uniforms before thousands
of spectators light meant life for the
miners and was as essential to their
equipment as their picks my grandfather
my great grandfather all worked in the
mind and they kept this tradition and
passed it on special here is that the
mining tradition is still so alive a lot
of young people are leaving the region
but it's heartwarming to see that the
culture is maintained and that it
attracts so many visitors every year in
the apps' mountains Christmas and
tradition are inextricably intertwined
now we meet up with Beniamino juarez
from santiago de chile while traveling
around germany he decided to explore the
medieval city of Marburg during the
winter the castle and old town provide
the perfect backdrop of a festive season
hola hello my name is Benjamin Alvarez
and i come from santiago de chile join
me in exploring Marburg today Marburg
has beautiful buildings with fascinating
architecture
income part of my Marburg visit is the
climb to the castle so let's go
we're almost at the castle and here the
first thing we see is art
incredible this is completely new for me
because we have no castles in Chile
mom hey you have a view of the whole
city with all its nooks and crannies the
buildings and roofs are so colorful and
the alleyways so narrow a truly friendly
City
how did you like the castle now let's go
down to the city now we're on marble
central marketplace the buildings look
like straight out of a fairy tale behind
me is City Hall looks like a fairy tale
illustration - and all around in a
centuries-old half-timbered houses Santa
Claus this is the famous leap who can
I've heard so much about let's try it a
big heart but delicious
what an experience I felt like a child
on a ferris wheel again
incredible there are so many people here
whole families children grandparents
they've all come here to have fun it's
the opening day of the Christmas market
I
when I think of my family and Chile
where it's 30 degrees right now then the
cold here seems strange but it's just
fantastic to experience Christmas in
Germany
Merry Christmas Marburg our final stop
takes us to the breathtaking winter
wonderland of best Asgard in a land and
lake konigssee situated in the middle of
the alps it beguiled Bavarian Kings
today it's an ideal holiday destination
for winter sports enthusiasts and nature
lovers
at 2713 meters the VATS van Massif in
the Bavarian Alps towers majestically
over the region known as Bosch discard
none light winter is the perfect time to
enjoy this imposing backdrop the Baptist
garden area is a popular destination for
winter sports enthusiasts the
family-friendly Rossford ski resort
always has enough snow there are more
than 100 kilometers of trails for
cross-country skiers tourism has become
the region's most important business
in the past the area was noted mainly
for its rich salt deposits salt mining
was its economic backbone you can take
an adventure tour through part of the
mine which is still in operation today
some 400,000 tourists a year take the
opportunity to go underground and learn
about the history and techniques of
mining in the middle of batches Garden
National Park lies Lake conexes a 600
meters above sea level
when it's not covered with ice you can
cross it on an environmentally friendly
electric boat slipping quietly past
dramatic scenery
the steep cliffs of the Alps rise almost
vertically from the water
the echoes of a bugle ricochet off the
mountains our destination is a place of
pilgrimage st. Bartholomew's Peninsula
with the chapel of the same name but
Peninsula is easily reached by boat on
foot it's a long and often arduous hike
the parts of the chapel date from the
12th century there are plenty of
spectacular hiking trails in back to
Scott National Park like the one that
leads to Klaus bak Valley where Park
Rangers feat the Red Deer in winter the
town of Bacchus garden is the region's
center of tourism travellers have been
coming here since the 19th century to
use it as a base for exploring the
surrounding countryside the buildings
painted facades like these on palace
square are typical of upper bavaria
right next to the abbey church is the
bestest garden royal palace once an
Augustinian monastery after 1810 it was
used mainly as a hunting lodge and
summer residence by the Bavarian kings
there are regular guided tours of the
business Bach art treasures and weapons
collections
yeah here in the middle is a papal sword
a sword that was awarded to Prince
elector Maximilian who first likes a new
young the palace is still home to
descendants of the vittles bark dynasty
and in two stricken on the doorframes
are records of the members of the
Bavarian royal family who stayed here in
the hunting season and summer months
here are the heights of the children
teenagers and adults with a name and a
date there's king ludwig ii as crown
prince aged about 6 and here you can
decipher elizabeth she later became
emperor [ __ ] kaiser on this eve only 30
of the 120 rooms in the royal palace can
be seen on the tour because descendants
of the Bavarian kings still live in bash
this garden palace today
that's all for this special edition of
discover Germany goodbye and auf
wiedersehen
you